what's popping rockstars my name is mt
and when episode four a falcon and the
winter soldier dropped
so did bucky's arm in a couple of
bucky's tears
and all this droppings were courtesy of
io
of the dora melange we learned that six
years prior to the show io had spent a
good amount of time
working with bucky to remove all that
annoying nazi nonsense in his noggin but
it wasn't just some regular
counselor client relationship like the
one bucky has with dr
touch thighs with your black bestie
rayner not sure what that's about but
okay
oh no it is quite clear that these two
have a deep history together
specifically the history of bucky's time
as wakanda's
white wolf which begs the question what
was the secret history between bucky and
io anyway i mean io seemed pretty damn
upset at bucky for playing
zemo man far from home with the very
same dude
who blew to chunks out of t'chaka at the
u.n
in civil war she even says bust damn you
james after hitting
control alt delete on bucky's arm and
bast is of course the well-revered
panther god of wakanda and i don't know
if any of you guys have gone to a
wakandan sunday school but
thou shall not use the name of cats in
vain is literally
the first of the ten best commandments
so that's how you know that this grace
jones looking chick is pissed as hell
but i bet you io will be even more
pissed if she saw you guys wearing the
sweet ass
puppet master shirts that we have for
you at newrockstarsmerch.com
it's got zemo playing with sam and bucky
like they were in sync in the year 2000.
it's great
go get it but anyways i need you all to
keep in mind that bucky spent a full
two years in wakanda between the events
of civil war
and infinity war and while i'm sure it's
nice to think that he spent all that
time discovering
what seasoned food tastes like you don't
earn the name
white wolf just by feeding cows with
little black children that'll watch you
while you sleep
the title of white wolf was actually
held by a member of extreme importance
to the continued safety
and security of wakanda in the marvel
comics a caucasian wakandan by the name
of hunter no last name provided because
if you're the only white guy in wakanda
you kind of don't need a last name
graciously taken in by king t'chaka
after a plane crash near wakanda killed
both of his parents
over the course of hunter's life he
would engross himself deeply
within the culture of wakanda and
eventually become the leader of the
hathat
zarazei wakanda's dogs of war the hattut
zorazei served as wakanda's
cia secret police that dealt with
anti-wakandan shenanigans at home
and abroad like if your ass all the way
in seattle was even
thinking about plotting to steal any one
of
wakanda's many vibranium rocks to add to
your rock collection
knock knock who's there it's the hot tub
zarazei
and we do get a glimpse of the war dogs
of wakanda in the mcu with secret agent
nakia
as well as a flashback sequence between
njobu and
fake friend zuri at the beginning of
black panther the cinematic experience
also you gotta remember that wakabe did
allude to war dog spies
hiding out in london new york and hong
kong that are ready to go
at a moment's notice just say the word
just say it now
given that bucky now holds the title of
white wolf within the mcu
as well as this newly implied past
connection
with io that i do not believe is
romantic whatsoever so please
put the fan fiction pen down for like
five minutes good god i think bucky
may not have been the white wolf in name
alone
i believe that wakanda in their great
wisdom took advantage of bucky's unique
particular set of skills and had him
work closely with io
nakia and the rest of wakanda's war dogs
to defend wakanda's interests
from those who are malicious and find
rakandan resources delicious
and if you think about it this makes
sense because a wakanda
isn't a black bed and breakfast and
bucky probably had to do something to
repay for all of wakanda's healing
and hospitality b sending bucky on
missions outside of the country is a
great way to keep him out of wakanda as
much as possible
until they can learn to trust him and c
at the end of black panther t'challa
exposes the true face of wakanda
on the world stage at the united nations
so now everybody in the world knows that
this tiny african nation is the most
advanced
and richest nation in the entire milky
way galaxy
which now opens wakanda up to a whole
new host of problems but
before i get into all that heads up gang
now i know that you
guys have probably heard us talk about
helix mattresses how great they are how
they're selected to fit your
specific sleep needs blah blah blah blah
all that stuff but i bring you good news
because our friends have helix have done
what humanity thought was previously
impossible and has started
making sofas for your butt helix just
launched a new company called all form
and they're making the most awesome
sofas ever
all form lets you customize a sofa using
premium materials at a fraction of the
cost of traditional stores you can pick
a fabric you can pick the color of the
legs the sofa size and the shape to fit
you
and your home it's super convenient
they've got everything from arm chairs
to eight-seat sectionals which are great
for a big family movie night or
if you're a single person like me a
great place to put all your action
figures for a long
and thoughtful discussion you do that
too right oh oh
it's just just me all form sofas are
delivered directly to your door
with fast and free shipping they'll get
you your custom furniture in three to
seven days
and you can assemble it without any
tools required that's right you don't
even need your tool of an uncle to show
up and help you out it's that easy and
what's great is that you get 100 days to
decide if you want to keep it and if you
don't love it they'll pick it up for
free
and give you a full refund and they even
offer a forever warranty
like literally forever like do you know
how many years are in forever
me neither but it's got to be at least
12. to find your perfect sofa check out
allform.com new rockstars and all form
is offering 20
off of all orders for our audience at
allform.com
new rockstars all form go help out your
butt
but anyways yes while this did set up
wakanda to start making more
sovereign foreign allies abroad this
move also puts an even bigger target on
wakanda's back because you gotta
remember kids
claw was one of the few people alive
that even knew the real deal behind
wakanda
and that mother went cuckoo for
wakanda's cocoa puffs so imagine that
times several hundred thousand now that
the entire earth can now
smell what wakanda is cooking t'challa's
plate just got a lot more fuller dealing
with a ton of new hostile forces
looking to either harm the royal family
or five-finger discount
all of wakanda's hard-earned [ __ ] and
this has pretty much been wakanda's
curse
in the comics since the days of bashanga
the first black panther
and the beginnings of wakanda in general
and remember that rhodey is
also about to deal with his own set of
greedy fingers looking to steal
tony stark's iron man technology in
armor wars on disney plus so it's easy
to see that the world of the mcu has a
proven
thirst for technological advancement by
any means possible
and walter shaw has been known to deal
with threats to wakanda himself
as black panther he now has to navigate
the world
more so as a king rather than the weapon
that he is
because if a king is caught breaking
rules and murdering fools on
foreign soil for the good of wakanda
that could still jeopardize
wakanda's perception of the world stage
and put t'challa's vision for a unified
world at risk as well
so what does t'challa do instead he lets
the dogs out
and uses this as an opportunity for
bucky to prove himself loyal to the
wakandan throne by having nakia and io
use him as part of the war dogs
counter-espionage efforts
with sherry of course playing the role
as the girl
in the chair guy in the chair which
opens the door for a sick-ass
international spy series within the mcu
that i would like to call
the white wolf and the war dogs of
wakanda a series where the three of them
team up and sneak around with various
wakandan sleeper agents
around the globe and this is where we
see io's perception of bucky go from one
of distrust
to that of a fellow arm of the king as
wakanda's white wolf
and also where bucky picks up some cool
new sneaky sneak sneak stealth
techniques that sam
teases him for in falcon in the winter
soldier little time in wakanda and you
come out white panther
it's actually white wolf huh and i
personally like to think that bucky was
gradually rewarded
with slightly upgraded prosthetics with
every successful mission
like he would start off with a
completely white non-vibranium metal arm
that was significantly weaker than his
original winter soldier arm
and then as he proved himself more and
more valuable and worthy
sherry and io would gradually provide
the white wolf with stronger white metal
arms until finally he is awarded that
black vibranium arm that we see
presented to him in infinity war to
symbolize bucky's full acceptance into
the community and that this white
is truly down with the brown however at
this point during his rehabilitation
the winter soldier is still gonna win
her soldier and during one of their
missions together it is
highly likely that bucky briefly reverts
back to his ruthless ways to get the job
done despite
not even being activated and while this
may prove beneficial to wakanda because
the mission
would have been completed technically
wakanda has always been about
stopping problems before they even start
so i can see t'challa's wisdom leading
him
to have sherry install the very same
failsafe that we see
ao implement in episode four falcon in
the winter soldier but anyways getting
to explore
more of the inner workings of wakanda's
intelligence agency would not only be an
amazing way to get a better idea
of the threats that neighbor wakanda's
borders threats like
the hostile country of naganda in the
comics but bucky's past
as the white wolf could also help plant
the seeds for neymar's subaquatic nation
of atlantis as atlantis ends up becoming
one of wakanda's greatest political
foes so much so that their beef
eventually evolves into the craziest
all-out war in the comics like neymar
does not come to the surface to [ __ ]
around
well unless it's with mr fantastic's
wife
got him and like i said before wakanda
has always been about
stopping problems before they start so
if anyone is going to be the first to
discover
and interact with atlantis it's probably
going to be the war dogs of wakanda and
good god
is some [ __ ] going to go down afterwards
this all being said there are definitely
some deeper threads that connect
to the reactions that io and bucky have
after io
turns bucky into marvel's very own arm
fall off boy
bucky feels absolutely betrayed that his
wakandan war sister
would know of a secret eject switch that
wakanda installed into his arm
and not tell him about it and io feels
even more betrayed that bucky would
attempt to have
any dealings let alone free king to
chaka's murderer
despite knowing how much of a threat
zemo could actually be
to their king because if you remember
black panther is also
a super soldier protecting wakanda is
the war dog's prime directive
and their former war dog betrayed the
pack and this is why i believe
ayo doesn't refer to bucky as the white
wolf when she says
bas dem you james because she just
doesn't believe that his current actions
align with his past loyalties to the
wakandan throne
but that's just me what do you guys
think like do you guys think that
there's a deeper connection between io
and bucky that we have yet to see on
screen
let us know in the comments and of
course support this channel by checking
out our new
falcon in the winter soldier inspired
puppet master shirt that at
newrockstarsmerch.com
and of course you can find me on twitter
at mastertainment you can follow
new rockstars anywhere that we are on
the internet subscribe to new rockstars
on youtube and hit that notification
bell so you can get all of our cool
notifications whenever we upload new
cool videos
like fitness origins where eric and
tommy bechtold and philip molina
do fitness challenges it's all marvel
themed challenges check it out my name
is mt and thank you guys so much for
watching you guys are wonderful
and stay safe
[Music]
you